did you guys hear Star Wars is gonna be
back in theaters with new stuff this is
gonna be awesome huh
that was kinda weird yeah when I'm sure
it's just something George Lucas has to
get out of the system you guys I don't
think Lucas cares about the fans oh yeah
that's just crazy
you just wait until episode 1 comes out
is this just a flu
oh come on at least admit that Darth
Maul was cool and the podrace I guess
but now you scoffs mr. no bother you
that's it guys check it out
Star Wars on DVD original Cup well
didn't you hear Lucas won't put out the
original versions you paid money for
that I'd rather have these than nothing
well it wasn't so bad at its moments too
little too late
shut up check it out
original cut on DVD well yeah but
doesn't like come packaged with a
special edition so you're forced to pay
extra for a movie you don't even want
well yeah didn't you already show up for
the first set because Lucas said he'd
never put the originals out you know
what screw you guys I'm gonna go bask in
the glory of Han shooting first never
shot first they shot at the same time
shut up
hey guys the original trilogy is gonna
be on blu-ray oh no whoa he's not scum
messing with it is he I mean I he can't
be
keep telling you guys he doesn't care
about the fans what what did he add
hey all right George Lucas just so
Lucasfilm to Disney they're gonna make
another three movies sequels to the
original trilogy yay bummer I I think it
could work
I mean Lucas is just gonna be advising
like he did on Empire Strikes Back
okay I mean there's no way they can make
it any worse than they already did this
is gonna be made by people who care
about what fans think rather than being
overly possessive about the whole thing
and ignoring what we think I guess
no no I'm starting to feel good about
this I'm surprised you did not try and
put a damper on his enthusiasm no he can
have his moment let the Wookiee win
that's surprisingly nice of you it's
just gonna make it funnier when this
whole thing turns into a disaster and he
crashes and burns and we're back